hey what's up guys my name is eterno and
welcome to the second episode of my
flappy bird series today we'll be
setting up a display for our game using
LW jgm firstly let's open our project in
Eclipse then we'll right-click on the
SRC or source folder in our project and
choose new then class a class is really
just a collection of code that's meant
to do a specific thing or represent
something in this case we need to make a
class that essentially launches our game
so first let's set a package a package
in Java is essentially a folder
hierarchy that we use to organize our
code kind of like a namespace the first
couple of folders usually refer to the
domain name or company name you're
developing ours in reverse order so I'm
going to put comma sure no H dot
indicates a separate folder much like a
forward or backslash next we put the
name of this software project which in
this case is flappy remember all this is
just a convention so you could just put
games of flappy or anything else and
that would work fine later we'll add
more specific folders to deal with
elements in our game such as graphics
and sound but this class will
essentially be in the base folder now we
need to give this class a name this is
going to be our main class that is the
class that contains the main method
needed in order to start our game so I'm
just going to call this class main you
should always start your class name with
the capital letter it's not required but
it's a fairly strongly enforced
convention finally you can check this
box here if you like to let Eclipse
automatically create the main method for
you but I'm going to go ahead and type
it out myself so you can see after we
click finish we have our class let's
have the main method all you have to
really remember here is that whatever
code that is in this method is what
actually gets executed when you run your
game we'll leave it blank for now since
we don't have anything to put into it
yet let's declare some fields at the top
which will define some of the properties
of our game fields our variables that
can be used throughout their entire
class private means they are only
visible in this main class it refers to
the variable being an integer a whole
number and finally we're going to go
ahead and call the variable width and
then make another one for height this
will be the size of our window in pixels
1280 by 720 we'll also create a string
which is a bunch of characters called
title which will be the title of our
window I'll name it flappy next we'll
create a boolean a variable that can be
the true or false and call it running
this variable will dictate whether or
not our game
is currently running finally we'll make
a thread we'll get more into threads in
just a sec let's create a method first
called start this is what we'll use to
start our game we'll set running equal
to true and initialize our thread object
threads allow us to do multiple things
simultaneously there is no making one
here is because I want our game to have
its own thread instead of the default
Java one this makes sure that we only
perform certain things on this thread
particularly the rendering of our
display in the constructor we'll pass in
this referring to this class and
optionally we can give this thread a
name I'll call it display since it will
primarily be responsible for our OpenGL
code okay fantastic
but this will give you an error since we
passed in the class using the this
keyword referring to the class you're
currently looking at which isn't yet a
runnable class so let's go back up to
the top and implement runnable a
writable class is simply a class that
has a run method which will be forced to
create now the way this works is pretty
simple we passed in this when we created
the thread so when we start the thread
by calling thread dot start the new
thread will call the run method below
that we just created in this class
everything inside the run method will
now be executed on our new thread now
let's create our display inside the run
method will type in display dot set
display mode to new display mode with
comma height we'll have to import
display mode so hover your mouse over it
and make sure you import the lwg l1 not
the java one this line will set up the
size of our window to the width and
height we specified above now it looks
like we've got one big error but don't
worry
setting your display mode simply throws
an exception which we now have to handle
hover your mouse over that line and
slice around with try and catch there
you go all good inside the try block
lists at the title of our window - the
title variable flappy that we created
before and finally let's call display it
or create to create our display that's
most of the code done simple isn't it
now let's make our main game loop our
game will have to repeat certain events
as long as it's running we'll have to
keep updating our display by calling
display to update and if the user closes
the window we need to set running equal
to false if that happens our while loop
will be history
and we'll need to destroy our display to
close the window now we're ready to see
if our code worked
let's call new main dot start which will
create a new instance of our main class
and then call the start method which of
course will start our game the red dot
start will call our run method and we'll
get into our loop until we close the
window note that we can't simply call
the start method by itself since the
main method is static and our start
method is not let's launch our game by
clicking on the debug button and see
what happens great black screen which
seems to be the size we want it and has
the correct title we've succeeded
unfortunately that's not all well this
will probably work on all platforms Mac
and Linux by default we'll use opengl
2.1 or lower whilst windows will
typically use the highest version
available opengl 2.1 is too low for us
we want 3.3 so how do we get it we
request it before we create the display
we'll need to create a context
attributes object and set it equal to
three three since we want opengl 3.3
let's import contacts and trips
differently than what we did last time
we'll use the keyboard shortcut ctrl
shift o or command shift o if you're on
Mac to let Eclipse organize our imports
let's select the OpenGL context trips
rather than OpenGL ES and click finish
organized imports will import all
required classes that we're currently
using and is generally a much quicker
way to import classes it will also
remove any imports that we're not using
pretty neat now when we create our
display will create a new pixel format
and pass in our context object along
with a statement with profile call true
the OpenGL call profile means that any
old deprecated code will essentially be
removed so we're stuck with only the
ability to use codes still supported in
three point three that's great since it
will actively stop us from writing
old-school code that should be enough
however there is currently a bug with
our l w GL requests an OpenGL contacts
from Mac and possibly Linux as well
requesting three point three gets us two
point one and requesting three point two
guess I'll say the three point three or
four point one depending on the computer
pretty bizarre so basically we need to
set our contacts to trips three point
two if the game runs on Mac note that
this is for version two point nine point
one or veil
so hopefully this bug will be fixed soon
so how can we check if we're on Mac
let's go ahead and type in an if
statement to check to see if a certain
system property called OS name contains
the string Mac if so we're on Mac and we
can go ahead and set the context equal
to 3.2 and now we're done let's check to
see that our window still works
right
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please don't forget to leave a
like I'll see you guys in the next
episode
well we'll be setting up OpenGL good bye